bene attenti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovi che sono parigi oggi siamo
su un gioco un po c'è senso strano siamo
su pound
e vabbè non so cosa dire sono comunque
sono un tipo mi chiede jobs che cosa non
fare aiuto giudiziaia questo lancio nero
aspetta a saya porca tua madre aspetta
strada sbagliata e non c'è un tizio con
una roccia gigante in mano sai non
vorrei andare di qua effettivamente ci
sono un sacco di cose potrei farti
prendere questo e tirarglielo in bocca
muso una guarda come si fa
cosa devo fare qui come si gioca non
sono capace non so porca [ __ ] a posto
scusi non volevo ma è morto e non
aspetta che lì e vi posso decidere dove
tirarlo ok no no madonna che male c'è se
ti becco in faccia muori madonna li
aspetta mi chiedi pc siano beccarsi
perché di vista del diritto proprio
madonna aia cosa aiuto
l'ho preso l'ho preso l'ho colpito
veramente non sto capendo il senso di
tutto questo
qual è c'è un motivo madonna madonna che
scarso se veramente c'è un motivo del
perché ci sono 100 le rocce giganti devo
stargli dietro il più possibile perché
se di studio pareggio per non aver mai
giocato il traguardo è un signor
traguardo non ho neanche capito cosa sto
facendo
ragazzi per me questo è il nuovo e il
nuovo sui motori dreams e cioè per me
possiamo farci 20 episodi di soggiorno
molto semplice e bello e personaggi sono
belli pronto rispondo né acqua ci sono
delle rocce le prendo subito
quindi o sei squadre a pezzo di merda
meno uno
sono solo il ninja di questo gioco ma
diventa bellissimo salve se lo prenda
aia mancato madonna che mira brutta ciò
attenzione questo calo vedo messo bene
madonna io arrivo in un tirare non
tirano dritto e quello è fatto tirano
storti
ma cosa ha schivato cosa ecco il gioco
bellissimo ma come ho fatto a trovarlo
vieni qua un sulla guardia un sud ma non
riesco a non riesco a capire se pantina
la dritta tirato di fare un giro tipo
rovescio di tennis e g tira dritta tanto
il punteggio in basso non sto capendo
con che criterio è assegnato perché bue
strano c'è effettivamente potrebbero
mettere solo tipo 1 23 quando ogni volta
che la terni no hay que botta in bocca
ha preso madonna come tiro 6 schivato
aiuto cioè sto contando io perché il
punteggio in basso non lo capisco quindi
un peccato tv che risolvi da una roccia
cesta cosa proprio non l'ho capita
comunque sono quasi finiti alle rocce ne
manca una o due e sono tutte e due
dall'altra parte dove c'e di questa
notizia ho passati
aiuto aiuto sta puntando ad altra roccia
la prendo la prendo la prenderla prende
la prenderò pesa l'ho presa
bella bella mira perché forse lo figlio
buono
amica che botta ma poi lanciata da sti
tizi c'è veramente incredibile dove è
uscito fuori eccolo come pareggio ma lo
sterrato molto più volte io ma come
pareggio ma dai
bellissima bravo questa è questa se l'è
meritata questa per un grande giocatore
questo è e sport si chiama a casa mia da
ragazzi veramente difficile è atterrato
già due volte non mi ha preso non mi ha
preso stavolta non ha preso dai non è
vero stavolta la che non mi ha preso vi
giuro ma porco del demonio da ecco
allora e allora io e allora anche questo
però c'è prima mi ha sfiorato anche il
solo sfiorato perché le nemmeno guarda
guarda come prima ma dai porca vacca ma
porco demonio è veramente difficile che
falso movimento madonna suo figlio
malizia andato sull'altra roccia ma no
ci siamo sforzati entrambi bellissimo va
bene a volte difficile però devo
atterrando tipo altre due volte sono a
rischio
occhio dai vari anche bravo perché fare
finte c'è proprio sveglio solo lo vede
lo uccide lo punisce proprio lui
attenzione vi lascerà la donna che
rischio continua da subito ok vela
buonissimo madonna che mira sto
recuperando lega sto recuperando buono
buono buono ma dai
se fossero esplorato un secondo prima
aveva tentato madonna dalla distanza
vedo che ve l'abbiamo più io e tipo un
dodge ball un po più peso attenzione
godo tie dye l'ho beccato dai ma dai sei
scherzando quote da ragazzino è vero e
di tornate in vantaggio con quattro
atterramenti hanno fatto i tre o due
tipo troppo aprirla mai visto e non
riesco a prendere la robaccia sta fuori
e non sta troppo fuori non ce la faccio
non schivare questo andare a prenderlo a
schiaffi attenzione fa niente
basta ai ma perché gli scafi non valgono
nulla aveva niente da jan 15 secondi
impegniamoci dove sono le rocce mancanti
ne manca solo una ci siamo uccisi
ho vinto io
da ora che non sto capendo la perché
vinco mondo per c'è stavolta
teoricamente avrei dovuto perdere ma
come bello bello
mi piace sto gioco proprio da un non so
che di intelligente i miei è il parco di
video che ho sul canale effettivamente
ci siamo 3 2 1 per battaglie della vita
siamo con eccolo lì partenza
questo è difficile perché tutte in piano
e in tutta in montagna
comunque vi piace sta roba che c'era una
mappa sola però la pappa per l'arena si
sposta randomicamente quindi fico
dell'idea dunque c'è anche la versione a
pagamento visto gioco che costa 10 euro
la compro immediatamente non so cosa sia
ma la compra a scatola chiusa proprio
voglio farci 86 video qualsiasi cosa
esso sia qualsiasi cosa è uscito dai
creatori visto dalla testa di cristo
gioco io lo voglio avere edizione s'è
mosso sottomissione uscire solo troppo
forte come mai io sono bravo di giochi e
fanno cagare stare però una plaga il
bellissimo non riesco a fermarmi e
bellissimo il gioco bellissimo o due
pareggi tre vittorie non ho mai perso
mai nemico
eccolo a covelo manca è svenuto non l'ho
toccato io giuro ecco l'ho preso ma dai
eccolo lì con che mira a video riesca a
mandare esattamente doveri dove voglio
tipo miracolo cela dietro se si è
professionista appiccicato alla schiena
che non riesco a colpirlo perché proprio
da appiccicato quindi no però se sono
abbastanza distante si pu a dai lo colpì
nella savana è rimbalzata pure quindi si
è visto che l'ho colpito però avere
forse con rimbalzo non vale pro questo
sì porca vacca l'ho mancato penserà che
questo è buono perché poi ti lascia la
roccia proprio una dinamica di gioco
pazzesche attenzione no mai fregato mi
ha fatto un bel è stata testata forte mi
è piaciuto mi è piaciuto agli attenti
atteso la mia
ma perché uscite l'ultimo dai voglio
finire una partita perché poi alla fine
se finisci c'è anche il duello però
quello ancora non abbiamo visto vorrei
vederlo sulla nuca fortissimo poi se
giocasse suo gioco da una vita
lo intuisce lo punisce proprio lui è
lanciare la maledizione po questo non ha
capito come si gioca devi lanciarla
contro di me sono fuori come se giocassi
da una vita gioco da dieci minuti ma
porco demonio porco com
ma davvero stavo cliccando mi sembra
poco
quando il calciatore tira da fuori area
la stessa cosa i la minchia che mira
sporco il demonio lo carico lo carico
deciso a non cito forum
ora ci sono non voglio avere giusto ed a
mista roccia ok e vabbè che spiega poi
un fortissimo dai che risparmia qua lo
so io trenta secondi restanti volevo far
fuori tutte le rocce per vedere che
succedeva sotto leghe e allora telo
procurarselo servita questa lancia la
dai a me la devi lanciare porco demoni
uomo spara qua
e invece noi che sono tali che minchia
come l'ho mancato 10 secondi peccato
all'ultima roccia quella poteva non
sfruttarla per vedere cosa succederà
dopo
ai a port conte lo sa forse sei ho
capito perché primo vinta
[Musica]
non sono proprio sicuro di aver capito
come funzionava bene questo era pounds
il momento più alto del mio canale da
quando ho aperto il canale credo spero
che vi sia piaciuto ammessi cosa sento
ragazzi seguito più dura sul documento è
un mi piace anche vari sociale con
descrizione ma se dovessi discrete vi
era come sempre ci vediamo hanno
costituito fatemi sapere se volete altri
di questo è particolarmente perché bei
ragazzi
[Musica]